today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so it's a new week and we are
essentially at the start of the 2020
election
right now now of course we've been
figuring out who's going to be the
democratic nominee people have been
campaigning for
a year now but what i mean is we are now
just weeks as i told you last week from
the first
votes early voting and absentee voting
starting in in
at least three states in just over five
weeks so
we need to have a very precise plan for
the next five weeks
and of course for the three months until
the november election and the plan
as much as being an offensive plan
against
donald trump in order to remove donald
trump the left needs a defensive plan as
well and i mean defense
against self-destructive elements of the
left so that we don't
self-destruct and allow donald trump to
get another four years in office
which would be i mean listen i don't
want to be hyperbolic i don't
even want to assign language to it right
now because it's not the point of the
story
but another four years of trump would be
very very bad let's put it that way
and one of the things that we have to be
very careful of right now
is for the left to avoid engaging
in fights that right now are irrelevant
and could potentially simply allow trump
to get another four years my advice for
the left
first of all my advice is for the left
and not for the right because i'm on the
left the right is making all sorts of
mistakes i hope they continue to make
mistakes and we should let them make
mistakes this is not about giving the
right advice
this is about giving the left advice but
at the same time
we should understand how certain fights
that are right now irrelevant don't
need to be put aside forever we just
need to be thinking
carefully about what we're doing and
that's where i want to go first
this is not a disclaimer but it is a
clarification
this is not about compromising
progressive policy or values
this is just realizing we have three
months left
we have to come together these three
months are the last thing we have to
remove donald trump and we have to put
policy differences within the left
that are currently irrelevant aside
because if trump wins
our chances of getting anything done are
zero in other words
the intra-left debates if trump wins
will be irrelevant for four more years
because either way we're not getting
anything done with donald trump in the
white house again
if joe biden wins then we go right
back to these disagreements within the
left because the point is
what do we want to push joe biden to do
what can we push joe biden to do
from the left and if democrats were able
to take the senate in november
which is looking more likely now than it
was a month ago i'll talk about that
later
it becomes an even more important
discussion now what i'm specifically
looking to here
are some of the different wings of the
left where there are disagreements
and what i want is for everybody to
understand
that we don't lose anything by
postponing these disagreements for three
months
and we do ourselves a lot of good
without harming the movement now i'll
give you some examples to make this
really clear i don't want this to just
remain
some vague thing socialism versus social
democracy
okay this has become a very important
popular relevant heated debate
on the left lately right now that debate
does nothing for us
it actually does nothing for us in two
different ways number one
whether you want socialism or social
democracy
the next step is social democracy from
where we are today there's no way the
united states
is going to be a socialist country
anytime soon when trump warns the
marxists are taking over
that's not true uh when the the right
warns the u.s could become socialist if
biden wins
that's not true and when the socialists
left says
we could have a socialist revolution and
be a socialist country
none of those things are happening
anytime soon and so the point is
if you are a socialist which i happen
not to be
you are going to have to come through
social democracy to get to socialism
that's the reality
with biden we have the opportunity to
get some policy done that is socially
democratic if you look at biden's ideas
on
health care taxation climate change
clean energy
they're not exactly what i want and i'll
address that later
but they're closer to the direction that
both
social democrats and socialists want to
go from where we are
today so we're not going to finish that
fight in the next three months we're
just not let's get trump out
and then let's start pushing biden in
the direction we all agree he
needs to go at some point in the future
if we succeed
socialism versus social democracy will
be relevant to policy
it's not the next step it's not
happening in the next three months so
why are we going to argue about
that right now when we're trying to
remove donald trump
just some other little examples here's
one that i thought of just looking at my
twitter this morning
there's this journalist mehdi hassan and
we follow each other on twitter i've
read it retweeted some of his work that
i think is great
uh he's retweeted some of our stuff
we're in agreement about many many
things
we happen to disagree maddie and i about
bds with respect to israel boycott
divestment sanctions movement
i believe that the movement is
counterproductive i don't think it will
lead to the kind of change i want to see
mehdi hassan supports bds great it's a
disagreement it's a completely
irrelevant one for the next three months
because we have a president
i think both media and i would agree we
have a president right now
who's in bed with the worst of the
israeli right in his support of benjamin
netanyahu
and has the worst instincts period when
it comes to the israeli-palestinian
conflict
so we're both against benjamin netanyahu
we're both against donald trump
trump must be removed so why would we
argue about bds
for the next three months rather than
focusing on removing donald trump
another example which is maybe more
relevant to you in the immediate
single-payer health care trump is not
for single-payer
neither is joe biden what joe biden is
proposing
is better than what donald trump is
proposing and most democrats in the
senate
don't even support single-payer health
care right now so
for the next three months why would we
make the dividing line
does biden support single-payer or not
it makes no sense
either biden or trump are going to be
inaugurated on january 20th
health care will improve if biden gets
his way
we can push him to improve it even more
hopefully
and with trump we get nothing we get
fewer people covered if trump gets his
way so what are we doing
now for people who are going to react
very negatively to what i'm saying
and they'll write to me and they'll say
david you're only saying this because
you're not a socialist and you are a
democratic party shill or whatever
argument
you're going to make you're missing
exactly the point that i'm making
whether or not i'm a democratic chill
and
by the way i'm not i'm not even a
democrat has no bearing whatsoever
on the left having opportunity with joe
biden
and none with donald trump that's it and
it's particularly important right now
not to operate for the next three months
in a way that will
serve to divide the left and give donald
trump in the right an
opportunity to be elected for another
four years partially
by fomenting this division on the left
which is exactly what they want to do
on january 21st if joe biden is
inaugurated on january 20th on january
21st
we have the ball back as i like to say
and we immediately go back to these
important discussions we immediately go
back on january 21st
to seeing the republicans in the lincoln
project this republican group trying to
remove trump
as soon as biden's inaugurated they're
no longer on our side i imagine they
immediately go back to advocating for
their
you know so-called small government
conservative values or whatever
these are all discussions you know about
health care or whatever topic
we go right back to those discussions
and in fact
if we do get the ball back uh
which i would that's how i've been
analogizing
removing trump and electing joe biden
once we get the ball back
we then have to try to put some points
on the board and that means
arguing about the right plays to call
and having these policy debates but at
this point
it's july 27th if we miss the forest for
the trees we're not just doing the
united states a disservice
we're doing the world a disservice given
the level of destruction that donald
trump has reigned upon this country
over the last three and a half years so
this is not
shut up and get in line with democratic
party centrism and cronyism that's not
what this is about this is about we get
nothing if donald trump gets reelected
the world will hate us even more
it will ruin our relationships with
allies even more
it will put us even further behind on
climate change irreparably so
versus we get trump out
biden goes in hopefully with a
reasonable reasonable vice president i
which we
should know soon i want to know who the
cabinet will be
we want to keep looking at the policy
and we have an opportunity
if joe biden gets elected now there will
be a contingent of my audience
that will disagree on principle with
what i'm saying
because they are in the camp of you've
got to burn it all down to build it back
up
um and these are some of the same folks
who said if it's not going to be bernie
in 2016
i don't care if it's trump because it'll
accelerate
the destruction of the country well
we're really no closer to any kind of
socialist revolution
as a result of four years of trump but
we are destroying the planet
we're in the middle of arguably one of
the worst five global responses to this
pandemic coronavirus pandemic
which has subsequently led to an even
worse economic disaster than was
necessary
it it's failed that that approach has
failed and go back and check out my
clips where i point out
the progress in the modern political era
has been incremental progress
by getting better people in getting
better people on the supreme court
and moving things in the right direction
so let's come together
let's do the right thing and i promise
you in three months
we can get right back to the same
divisive debates
if that's what you want to do hopefully
in a more productive way
with the experience and hindsight
of seeing what we experienced during the
donald trump
presidency if we get another four years
of trump who knows
what's next but it's not good so let's
come together on this issue
this is not a long time you know for
people desperate to talk about uh
a a socialist revolution to knock out
neo-liberalism and you know that wing of
of my audience
three months is not a long time let's
just put that energy to get out the vote
and removing donald trump it's just
three months okay it's gonna go look
we've been in quarantine for five months
it's gone by like that because every day
looks very very similar
these three months will go by quickly
even during the transition we can get
back to these debates if that
that's what you want let's do it let's
come together for the next three months
let me know where you disagree with me
i'm on twitter at deepakman and remember
you can get the daily
audio podcast from the david pakman show
every single day right around 3 p.m
eastern noon pacific
on any of your favorite or least
despised podcasting apps whether that's
google play podcasts or spotify pandora
uh iheartradio itunes etc etc get the
daily audio podcast let me know what you
think about avoiding these
self-destructive and presently
irrelevant debates on twitter
at d pacman and i will be back with much
more
just moments from now the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
matthew brooks and richard connelly
thanks to both of you and also a big
thank you to mary ballard johansson
who's today's longtime
sustaining member of the day mary's been
a member almost five years i remember
the day
a while ago where mary was new member of
the day
and now mary look how far you've come
sustaining member of the day
unbelievable
grab a membership at joinpacman.com it's
quick
it's cheap it's easy and you will also
get the daily
bonus show very very exciting stuff
is donald trump actually instituting the
martial law
that we were warned barack obama was
actually going to institute if you were
paying attention to politics during the
barack obama administration
you might remember the unhinged
belligerent
fear-mongering from the right that
barack obama plans to enact martial law
in the united states
some versions of the conspiracy said
that it was part of a plan to enslave
people in fema camps sometimes rfid
chips were involved sometimes not
uh and all of this was part of obama's
bigger plan to suspend the 2012 election
which he didn't do
and then it was actually about
suspending the 2016 election and
remaining in power indefinitely while
bringing authoritarian militaristic
terror to the streets of america
against the wishes of state and local
authorities and elected officials
and if you were paying attention you
knew that barack obama
had no interest in doing any such thing
there was no chance whatsoever that that
was what barack obama was going to do
but that gets us to today and we
actually have to have a discussion today
about whether donald trump
is indeed instituting martial law by the
forceful deployment of paramilitaries to
cities around the country
where if you look at portland for
example those troops have
tear-gassed the mayor of portland more
on that later
attacked reporters and journalists and
so the first
step is what is martial law if we don't
know what it is it's hard to determine
whether we are seeing it well martial
law is when normal
civil functions and civil law are
replaced by military control
sometimes martial law can be declared
during a real
or fabricated emergency situation as a
lead
up to or after a coup in the context of
a natural disaster or states of
emergency and there's some other
situations as well
and often martial law includes any or
all of the following
the military in the streets working as
local law enforcement
curfews the suspension of habeas corpus
and normal due process
military law and justice being applied
to civilians
so do we have literal martial law today
in the united states
no we don't is what donald trump has
done so far
literal fascism it's not but
we are seeing what the early phases
of potentially future widespread martial
law could look like
if slowly deployed now if you deny this
basic fact
you're denying reality right now it's
not all happening at once it's not
completely obvious unless you look step
by step
but that's what makes it harder to see
and in fact authoritarian dictators
understand this and they often deploy
martial law in baby steps now again to
be completely clear
i am not saying we will soon have a
fully authoritarian police state martial
law situation
in the united states and part of the
reason we may not
is trump will run out of time he will
either win reelection
and no longer need these authoritarian
escalations to try to help himself get
reelected
or he will lose and as far as i'm
concerned he will leave
office and thus it will stop the
escalation as well
but think through the steps donald trump
is deploying
federal troops armed paramilitaries to
cities and towns
these troops aren't part of the normal
military branches they're part of
homeland security but they really are a
military that is
functioning at the pleasure of the
president as local law enforcement
overriding local law enforcement
camouflaged with body armor carrying
heavy weapons
throwing people into unmarked vans even
local politicians and reporters are
getting hit
now many of them are being released
after being thrown
into a van and brought to who knows
where and
it's true that when you look at some of
the worst police states and martial law
situations of the last
40 50 years around the world many of
them don't release people without
charges if it turns out they don't want
to charge you
sometimes they bring you into a dark
room and they kill you and you never
hear from them again you never hear
you are never heard from again and this
happened to friends of my parents
in the 1970s during the military
dictatorship in argentina
that's not where we are and we're not
actually close to that right now
but at least colloquially they are
replacing
civil law with troops federal troops
quite literally
if mayors and governors don't want them
there they are
in conflict with local law enforcement
they are enforcing a sort of federal
military law and putting it above
supreme to local law enforcement
now the typical justification is being
given this also
fits with history which is that it's an
emergency
now this gets us into interesting
territory
the incredible thing is that we have
real emergencies right now
we have an emergency which is the
pandemic and the mishandling of the
pandemic by the federal government
meaning the trump administration
we have another emergency which is the
economic crisis happening
which is far worse than it had to be as
a result of donald
trump's mishandling of the pandemic but
that's not
the emergency that donald trump is
actually pointing to to justify these
troops in portland and chicago and other
places soon
trump is saying the emergency is out of
control
cancel culture protesters destroying
statues
and federal property and trying to burn
courthouses to the ground
that's not the real emergency in fact
that's not even actually happening as
described
the emergency is a thousand or more
people per day
again dying of coronavirus 11
unemployment
the pending eviction crisis cuts to the
uh
unemployment insurance benefits and the
like that's the emergency but that's not
why trump says he's sending in the
troops
so now they start bolstering this
environment of fear and panic
as a result of the federal troops being
there and people are starting to wonder
how long are we going to live like this
are we going to be able to vote
normally in november are these troops
going to be intimidating me at the
voting booth in november
by patrolling with heavy uh uh weapons
and this is quite literally the way it's
done this is out of the playbook
playbook
slowly creeping in to where we start
thinking
well it's normal to have the armed
paramilitaries
in cities across the country but this
next thing isn't yet normal but then you
get the next thing and okay now that's
normal
but the next thing isn't yet normal it's
the slow normalization
now there they have the benefit that
there are some people
already on the side of the
paramilitaries that's another
issue and we'll talk about that probably
not today but maybe later in the week
so if you're waiting for one day at
which
we confirm today at 12 15
p.m we have now reached martial law
or something like that by design that's
not how it happens
it started with years ago trump joking
about
maybe i'll stay in power i like the idea
of how china now allows the president to
be reelected indefinitely
trump attacking the free press kicking
out you know early on i think it was jim
acosta from the white house
uh briefings momentarily and you know it
starts with that attacks on the press
etc
that became normalized trump attacks the
press all the time now
barely gets attention well then now
there's troops in portland and soon in
chicago and other cities next
and some people are already fine with it
because they believe donald trump's
explanation for why
we need the troops to be there in the
first place and then before you know it
we have a national emergency with
paramilitaries deployed
nationwide regularly repressing
not just peaceful protesters with
flowers and signs but even attacking
journalists and members of the press
covering what's going on which we are
already seeing and could potentially
increase
and then you've got trump's federal
troops on election day
presiding over an election in which
trump himself
is trying to get himself re-elected if
you thought
secretary of state brian kemp in florida
running the election in which he was a
candidate for governor was bad
then think about trump deploying
paramilitaries
to supervise his own reelection
campaign this is how it creeps in and i
hope people are starting to see it
and realizing how important it is to put
a stop to this
and you know put a stop to it we may not
be able to stop
the deployment of the troops but by not
taking our eye off the ball
which is this is a desperate cornered
president who sees the polls and knows
as of today that he's losing
and he could be embarrassed in a
historic electoral college route by joe
biden if things don't change right
that's the whole point
he is now extremely desperate and that's
very dangerous
and so we need to make sure that at the
top level
this is not allowed to change the
character of the november election
in five weeks there are certain states
that can start early voting absentee
do it every single week do not be
dissuaded
keep your eye on the ball because we've
only got three months to go
we know the plan we know the slow
creeping
of authoritarianism we're seeing it
right now
we've been hearing about it from people
like timothy snyder and others for a
long time this is this is it this is no
longer rehearsal we've got three months
and this is the game plan and we're
starting to see the signs we're going to
continue
covering this on the david pakman show
instagram page which i
invite you to follow at david pakman
show
while you're there follow me on
instagram at david.pakman for a break
from the authoritarianism
non-politics uh non-political stuff
on my instagram page we'll take a quick
break i do want to talk about the latest
senate predictions
and so much happened over the weekend to
catch you up on
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the
easiest way is through membership which
includes the world famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
so let's talk about the senate huge
senate news
over the weekend according to the latest
update
from the nonpartisan cook political
report democrats are now
slightly favored to take control of the
senate from republicans in november now
what does this mean for
us nothing everyone has to vote no
matter what is going on
but let's actually discuss so back in
2019
i didn't think democrats had a good shot
at taking the senate in 2020.
um we have 100 senators every two years
one-third of them are up for re-election
and the third of the seats that were up
in 2020
were not in early 2019 looking very
favorable for democrats trump was
polling okay enough
that the incumbent republicans weren't
being hugely hurt and i did a story in
may of 2019 called
why democrats won't take the senate in
2020 and in the clip i say
this is the situation right now if
something changes i will update you
and then things sort of did change and
some seats started looking not quite so
good for incumbent republicans trump
wasn't doing so hot
and so by october of 2019 i did another
close analysis of each race each seat up
for re-election
and that got me to a point where i
revised my view
and told you in october of 2019
democrats could
take the senate in 2020. now
i've been following this closely for you
since and in may
of this year just a couple months ago i
did a story where
there was an uphill battle certainly but
a much clearer path for democrats to
take the senate and again i came back to
you on may 20th and i said
democrats could take the senate from
republicans and it was uphill but it was
a much more reasonable path
and things have now gotten so bad
for donald trump and incumbent
republicans even loosely associated with
him in the last two months since that
story
that the cook political report 100 days
out from this election
now says that democrats are favored
to take back the senate now it's a slim
margin but a slight edge to democrats to
take back the senate
is a dramatically different situation
than what we had 18 months ago now as a
reminder
right now the senate is 53 to 47
republicans over democrats of the 47
that i'm including on the democratic
side
it's actually 45 democrats plus two
independents
uh angus king and that guy bernie
sanders who are independents but caucus
with democrats that's where you get 47
democrats
and 53 republicans in july
five races changed in such a way that
the cook political report
changed their projection to a slight
edge
to democrats to control the senate the
changes in july
are in arizona martha mcsally
is losing pretty badly to mark kelly in
polls
and that has gone from a toss-up to
leaning democratic
in iowa joni ernst the incumbent
republican that race has gone from
leaning republican to a toss-up
in georgia david perdue's race has gone
from leaning republican to
a toss-up in minneapolis in minnesota
rather
tina smith went from likely democratic
victory to
solid democratic victory and then in new
mexico which is currently an open seat
uh it went from likely democrat tom
udall winning
to solidly democrat tom udall winning
now those are the changes in july
which have pushed the senate overall to
more likely to be taken uh control of by
democrats but
you've got a whole bunch of other races
that have not changed in july which
we've talked about colorado and north
carolina
are very vulnerable republican seats
that's cory gardner
and tom tillis those are leaning
democratic
in maine susan collins is in a real
uphill battle probably her toughest
re-election campaign
really ever i believe susan collins was
first elected it don't hold me to this
but i believe 96
meaning she had re-election campaigns in
2002
2008 2014 that makes sense and 2020
all of her other re-election campaigns
have been not particularly challenging
for her and sarah gideon at least in
some polls recently is actually ahead so
maine a tough one for republicans to
hold and really
maine should not have a republican
senator we they should replace uh
susan collins as soon as possible we've
talked about montana where
democrat steve bullock is doing well he
could end up being senator from montana
there are question marks around seats in
kansas
texas alaska and south carolina so
there's a whole bunch of different
possibilities and the point of this
story is not about
analyzing each of them in extreme detail
but about the idea
that what looked you know in early 2019
the data was saying maybe democrats can
pick up a seat or two
but taking control would probably be
2022.
uh and 2022 doesn't even look that
obviously great depending on which
states you're looking at
it shifted to there's a path
but all these different maybes need to
go the way of the democratic
challengers it is now shifted to you
know there's more races leaning
democratic and now you don't need as
much of a performance
outside of what would be reasonable to
take control of the senate and so that's
how now it is being called a
slight edge for democrats in the cook
political report so
this is all a way of me telling you what
to stay home and say
other people got it no of course not
this is a way of me saying
hey here is an opportunity
which we will only seize if we all go
out and vote
ignore every poll and go out and vote if
you don't like the republican senator
that is representing your state right
now
ignore the polls and vote and we'll keep
covering the senate outlook and the
this is particularly important because
of the conversation we had at the top of
the show
if joe biden wins him doing stuff
that we want him to do is going to
depend hugely on having the senate in
the first two years in office
historically when the white house
changes hands
in an election year two years later in
those midterms
that party that took control of the
white house often suffers losses
in the house and or senate we don't want
that
but what we can do in the immediate is
let's give joe biden if he were to win
a senate that is democratically
controlled and a house that is
democratically controlled if that
happens
the two years between january 21st uh
january 20th
2021 and january 2023
may be the biggest opportunity for
progressive change
in decades in the united states well i
guess we would put it up there
with the couple years between 2009 and
2011 when barack obama had the
opportunity
uh mishandled some things but also got
many things done
including obamacare so that's the
opportunity this is absolutely huge and
all you have to do is go vote you know
it can be overwhelming oh
tom udall and then martha mcsally and
all the
i can't focus on your scope of influence
focus on your sphere of influence which
is
am i allowed to vote oh i am because you
know i'm a citizen obviously
you can if you're if you're legally
voting then that's what you should do
i'm going to go and vote and that's all
i can control and then i can work on get
out the vote
and i can work on whatever else work on
what you can control and we have a real
opportunity here
dr anthony fauci the top infectious
disease doctor in the country
has revealed in an interview over the
weekend that he and his family
have been receiving serious threats as
he continues to try to fight the
coronavirus pandemic in the united
states
on the same day that we learned about
the threats
to dr fauci and his family the united
states
set another single day record with more
than
77 000 new coronavirus cases just shy of
78 000 new coronavirus cases
and the day after we learned that dr
fauci was being threatened
and his family was being threatened as
we hit a record of single-day new cases
donald trump went golfing for the 282nd
time of his presidency dr fauci saying
to david axelrod on
axis podcast quote there are people who
get really angry at thinking
i'm interfering with their life because
i'm pushing a public health
agenda the kind of not only hate mail
but actual serious threats against me
are not good
i mean really is this the united states
of america
but it's real it really is real
this has gotten so bad that dr anthony
fauci
a nearly 80 year old infectious disease
doctor who's been working for both
democratic and republican presidents for
what is it 40 years at this point
it's gotten so bad that dr fauci and his
family
now have a security detail
should be embarrassed donald trump and
his press secretary
are out there talking about oh paw
patrol
is canceled some show paw patrol
coronavirus is raging and the top guy
actually fighting the virus while trump
talks about paw patrol dr
fauci needs security for himself
and for his family because of threats
against them and people wonder why we
why why do we have all these cases why
do we have a hundred and we're about to
cross 150
000 dead americans while so many
countries have it under control
this is why this is why is the world
ever going to forgive us for this i saw
someone
on twitter say in response to uh
the the threats against fouchy and you
know everything that's going on
too bad we don't have a vaccine for
stupidity well we sort of do
it's called education right real quality
education
with uh people being taught media
literacy
and critical thinking that is a vaccine
against being victim of disinformation
propaganda we're lacking it
in a lot of the country now i you know
whenever i say this educators write to
me they say david
you know we're doing a good job here
there no doubt there is no doubt that
there is
plenty of great education in the united
states but
too much of the united states is lacking
it we know what the vaccine is
to stupidity we can produce it in mass
quantities but
we don't invest nearly enough in it as a
country i'm talking about education here
and lots of parents tell their kids you
don't really need that education and
this is where we are today
i made a mistake early on in this
pandemic
and i've been reading a bunch of
interesting pieces about it
over the last week from others who made
the same mistake
we didn't think that something so cut
and dry
like a medical crisis such as the one
we're experiencing
would see the country so divided along
the typical
political lines where one side says
health is the priority listen to doctors
take care of others trust in the
scientific method empathy etc
and another side would lead protests
against
masks spread conf conspiracy theories
about
dr fauci and bill gates show up
filming at walmart to show how patriotic
they are by refusing to wear a mask i
underestimated it
i thought this would bring people
together and we would do the right
things and
put those stupid political disagreements
aside but clearly i was wrong
and to go back to the fouchy piece dr
fauci has been thrown to the wolves by
this administration with donald trump
criticizing fauci rather than
criticizing fauci's detractors
the white house piled on publishing a
document of
what is essentially opposition research
about dr fauci
listing things the white house released
to the media
a document saying look at all this stuff
vouch you got wrong
well what about trump saying 15 cases
will soon be zero there's no
accountability for that
what about trump saying all of the
things that he has said can you imagine
dr fauci and bill gates
two of the people pouring time and money
in gates case
into solving infectious disease for no
personal gain bill gates donating what
is it is it hundreds of millions at this
point
uh to vaccination and dealing with
disease dr fauci is nearly 80 he's a
high-risk individual which he says is
why he's not stepping on a plane or
going to a restaurant
and yet he's seemingly working 24 7 and
they are attacked
conspiracy theories created about them
has about one third of the country gone
functionally insane
defining functional insanity is tough
but the gist of it is if you're
functionally insane
you can basically exist in society in a
semi-normal way like you could probably
hold a job for example
you're keeping your kids alive well
enough to to raise them to adulthood
that they may have some weird ideas but
you're keeping them alive
but then in practice they live believing
completely delusional things like dr
fauci is helping bill gates's population
control
uh wet dream agenda by
planning to rfid chip people with a
vaccine or
masks are making me lose my rights or
depriving me of oxygen or
it's reasonable to scream at a costco
employee because i don't want to wear a
mask and i think coronavirus is a photo
is a hoax is there a sort of functional
insanity here that we have to deal with
unclear but i feel terribly for dr
fauci and again is the world going to
forgive us for this
this has been one of the largest
mishandlings of
anything i mean listen katrina was a
disaster the way that george bush
handled katrina there is no
excuse whatsoever but compare the scale
of what we're dealing with now
and to call this trump's katrina
it understates actually what's going on
without in
any way minimizing the absolute
disaster that was george w bush's
handling of katrina
i don't even know what to compare it to
at this point in time and again
today probably by the time you hear this
we likely will have
surpassed the 150 000
death milestone i don't know
if we deserve to be forgiven
unfortunately for what this
administration has done or better said
not done in response to this virus we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this with the latest from portland
where the mayor has actually been tear
gassed if you can believe that
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so i sort of mentioned in passing in my
story about martial law
earlier in the show that the mayor of
portland was tear gassed along with
protesters recently by donald trump's
federal troops
operating under the banner of homeland
security but i never really gave you the
details of what happened there
so not only was portland mayor ted
wheeler gassed
president donald trump seemed to brag
about it
here's donald trump during an outrageous
fox news interview first of all notice
trump doesn't even know the guy's name
his name is ted wheeler
trump calls him waylon and then sean
hannity corrects him
and then trump brags about wheeler
getting
the hell knocked out of him and it's not
to be totally honest it's not clear if
trump's referring to gending tear gassed
or that he was booed
but take a look at the clip and then
we'll discuss and
they were going wild for 51 days and we
went in and
they've done a great job they're going
to rip down the courthouse a big federal
courthouse gorgeous federal courthouse
so we went in and we've been very very
strong and we have this
mayor whalen who i think is also he's
also
the police commissioner as i understand
it in florida
yeah uh mayor wheeler and he's uh
he made a fool out of himself list he
wanted to be among the people so he went
into the crowd and they knocked the hell
out of him
that was the end of him so it was pretty
uh pretty pathetic
but we want to go in and help the cities
we want to help chicago
so indeed a few days ago ted wheeler was
hit with tear gas while he was standing
with protesters
near the courthouse and just about
everything trump
says in that very short clip is false
trump calls the mayor whelan hannity
corrects him so he gets the guy's name
wrong
trump says that protesters were going
wild for 51 days that's
certainly not true again unless donald
trump is actually
you know some kind of physicist that has
a different conception of what time
means by no measure have the protesters
been going wild for 51 days
trump says the courthouse was going to
be ripped down that's
not true but the really shocking thing
here
is that it is so dictatorial and so
authoritarian
that trump is ridiculing ted wheeler for
being on the side of the public
against the federal paramilitaries in
other words
overwhelmingly people don't want these
federal troops in portland now
i've gotten a couple emails over the
weekend from people saying you know
david
you should see that there are like
individuals someone told me although i
haven't confirmed that brett weinstein
wants the troops there uh because he
says
you know the rest of the country doesn't
really understand what's going on i
don't i don't know if that's true i got
a few emails about that
overwhelmingly people don't want these
troops there
the mayor doesn't want the troops there
and
the local law enforcement authorities
are not working in conjunction with
these troops in anything
that would be called a cooperative way
and the mayor
as a citizen is joining the people
that's great now yeah the mayor was
booed
by some people when he did this and that
relates to you know people may be
displeased with the mayor's handling of
the situation
but shouldn't we like it when elected
officials
instead of hanging out in the safety of
their ivory towers
if portland has ivory towers i don't
know and making declarations
wouldn't it be better if people uh
were joined by elected officials
isn't that what we want to see now i
know that there will be situations where
it doesn't feel genuine and when mitt
romney a republican senator
joined the black lives matter protests
wearing a mask
no less in washington dc joining mostly
left wingers let's be honest about it
uh and he was asked what are you doing
here senator he said i'm here because
black lives matter and he kept his mask
on and he did it
there were people who said this is
disingenuous romney this is the guy who
was going to lower taxes on millionaires
oh yeah that's true it's romney it is
that guy he's still a republican
but i think it's important when a
republican says hey
i have to choose the movement over my
party in this particular case
i think that it should be applauded but
with some healthy skepticism that these
are still politicians who are
calculating what they do
the point is we should be glad
when elected officials join movements
rather than just
sending out messages on twitter or
hanging out in their office
and donald trump is ridiculing ted
wheeler for hearing the voice of the
people and joining them in their
peaceful protests
this isn't getting that much attention
but it is insanely authoritarian the
president
sits in dc and essentially laughs at a
public servant
who is joining people and says he got
the hell knocked out of him again it's
not was that from he was tear gas but
it's not clear if trump was referring to
that
so we have to recognize this for what it
is and to follow up on the earlier story
about martial law and authoritarianism
federal troops are being sent around to
different cities a growing list of
cities
to satisfy donald trump's whims and
to as trump sees it generate chaos
that will help get him reelected we just
can't allow it to work but this
is his plan now to get ahead of a
narrative that's being floated already
if you look in some reactionary and
right wing circles
there you might be shocked by this there
are some right wingers abandoning their
so-called
small government values and saying i
support
the paramilitaries because these
protesters deserve it
because they are criminals again the
protesters aren't criminals
they are protesters they are
constitutionally protected
it is speech they are peaceably
assembling
and they are asking for the redress of
of grievances that they are bringing
forward
if they are criminals then they are
criminals
right protesters aren't criminals
protesters are the patriots here and
that's the something the right doesn't
want to accept
the right has attempted to hold the
monopoly on patriotism in the united
states for a long time
certainly i was most exposed to it
around the 2003 iraq war but it's not
new it's been going on for decades and
decades
the protesters are being patriotic
they are doing the things that our
country was enshrined upon a protester
is not a criminal
now i've said before and i'll repeat it
some of you disagree
breaking windows at a courthouse is not
going to forward any cause and it is a
crime
and you're going to be suffering the
consequences of committing a crime if
you do it
setting fires to buildings is not going
to further any cause
and it's a crime and you should expect
that if you do that
you are going to be arrested and charged
and it could be really bad for you
martin luther king was very clear about
this mark there's some
very interesting contrast look up videos
of interviews with martin luther king
and separately with malcolm x both of
whom
were bringing a lot of different ideas
forward
valuable ideas uh martin luther king
differed from malcolm x
and that martin luther king recognized
that when you
start using more violent tactics
arson destruction of property etc even
if you can morally defend it even if we
can all say an insurance company will
pay to rebuild the building who cares
okay
that's aside from the fact that people
could get hurt or killed
as bystanders martin luther king pointed
out
it often comes back to hurt exactly the
people
doing the protesting and when you
consider that many of these protests are
overwhelmingly white do we really
improve the situation for the people
that we are most trying to help
by introducing elements of violence here
which may only lead to even rougher
treatment by police of the very people
we are trying to help so
i do see that as self-destructive right
this is not a show where if you're
tuning in for me
to defend criminality that's not this
show
but most of the people are just
protesters it's moms now who have showed
up
to back up the protesters and then
veterans
showed up to back up the moms who were
backing up the protesters so
we can't let them set the narrative of
the troops or fine
because it's really mostly criminals
there and the protesters are criminals
no we can't let them set that narrative
and not letting them set the narrative
is just part of
part of what we need to be doing for the
next three months
this next story is one of those it's
been a serious show this is one of those
funny stories that is really more about
donald trump's fragility
than it is about anything else donald
trump has suddenly backed out of
throwing out a first pitch
at an upcoming new york yankees baseball
game now
there are three different reasons why
and you can say that it's all three or
just one or two
you know take your pick first of all i
believe trump
is worried that he's going to really
screw up the first pitch and he's going
to be again
a an embarrassing laughing stock trump
is claiming that he's going to be too
busy to do it he tweeted yesterday quote
because of my strong focus on the china
virus including scheduled meetings on
vaccines
our economy and much else i won't be
able to be in new york to throw up the
opening pitch for the yankees on august
15th
we will make it later in the season so
this is not
credible this is the guy who just golfed
for the 282nd day during his presidency
he says he's gonna be too busy working
now to throw out a pitch which takes
five minutes he's so
fragile i get he has to travel to new
york he's so fragile he's afraid of what
will be a disastrous pitch
so that's number one now i want to be
clear
this is not about wait a second david
you complain trump doesn't do any work
and now you complain that he's going to
be working instead of throwing out a
pitch
you're being a hypocrite now trump's
just lying again
we know trump doesn't skip things that
he thinks will make him look good or
that are fun for him
because he has to work he's golfed 282
different days during his presidency
trump is skipping this because
especially after his skills playing
catch were ridiculed last week
when he tossed the ball around with
former yankee mariano rivera
he knows he could come up with an
embarrassing first pitch and it would be
really bad
he is scared someone might realize maybe
trump isn't the alpha male he makes
himself out to be
but here's the thing if you don't think
that's the reason why trump isn't going
to do it
there's another reason which is trump
doesn't want to get booed we're talking
about new york city trump was getting
brutally booed at sporting events
before coronavirus he was not losing to
biden by 10
and he was getting destroyed when he
went to sporting events with just brutal
boos
he was going to get obliterated with
booze at yankee stadium so
it's the pitch itself that he'd likely
mess up plus getting brutally booed at
yankee stadium and it being repeated on
tv for hours
but if you don't like either of those
explanations
entire baseball teams have been kneeling
during the national anthem
in the early days of this new major
league baseball season
it's another reason trump doesn't want
to be there for that
because again trump would be out there
with his hand over his heart
trying to remember the words the
national anthem while
all or most of the players would be
kneeling in
another direct rebuke of donald trump
so those pic which of these are all
three of these reasons
of course trump is bailing on throwing
out the first pitch and anyway
imagine claiming you're too busy to
throw out
a pitch the day after retweeting
as he did on saturday a picture of
himself and former nfl quarterback brett
favre
playing golf as 77 000 new coronavirus
cases had been announced the previous
day in the united states
it just doesn't pass the sniff test
that donald trump is not doing this
because he's too busy
he's just too fragile for me you know we
need a stronger president no i'm not
talking
physically i'm talking intellectually
i'm talking
emotionally personality wise trump is
just too fragile for me
i'm going to be voting for joe biden in
november we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
here is a fair question about joe biden
and it sort of relates to our
conversation
earlier let's take a listen to it um
david i would i just wanted to know what
were your
main critiques of biden
policies um i just wanted to notice
going into the 2020 election knowing
like
what do you disagree with him on
thank you got it okay so listen there's
no way to sum this up in one segment but
every time i've done an analysis of a
joe biden proposal
joe biden's health care proposal joe
biden's tax plan
joe biden on climate or whatever else
i will point out where he falls short
and i think what's important here is
context
so for example joe biden's tax plan
is actually quite solid it has a lot of
very good things in it it doesn't for
example
create new higher tax brackets i think
we need right now the highest tax
bracket i think is around 550 000
we probably need tax brackets like at
the 1.5 or 2 million dollar level
5 or 10 million 50 100 you know but we
need higher
levels and higher tax rates at those
higher
levels he doesn't do that that's a
critique of joe biden's tax plan
and joe biden's tax plan does a lot of
good things when we looked at
joe biden's clean energy and climate
change plan it does
many good things but it fell short in
some areas
in terms of certain requirements
pollution requirements
you know i outlined them in that clip
when we've talked about joe biden on
health care joe biden's plan
will give way more people access to
health care and it will make health care
affordable for way more people
but it's not going to be comprehensive
and universal as an example so
with all of these questions the reason
i'm doing this is
that's it feels to me that that
voicemail was a good faith question it
was not a question meant to
do this stuff of if it's not bernie then
who cares if it's trump
it seems like it's just i'm curious
where do you disagree with joe biden and
i disagree with joe biden in many areas
and yet the reality that i must vote for
joe biden
is not missed at any point in time and
it is abundantly and completely clear
and my critiques of joe biden have not
been done in a way
to even remotely suggest maybe we stay
home or vote for trump
joe biden's plans don't do everything
that we want them to do
taking the senate in november in
addition to winning the white house
would best enable us to have two
straight years two solid years
during which we can push the senate and
the house and joe biden
to pass as much progressive change as
possible and that's all we can really
say right now and so my goal from here
on out is
i have no problem critiquing joe biden's
policy where it falls short
and that's what i do if i wasn't doing
that i really would be doing you a
disservice
but i'm not going to do it in a way that
might leave anybody thinking
whoa is david sort of saying maybe we
don't vote for biden no i'm not going to
do that it's going to be made clear in
every single segment that that's what
has to happen
we have a great bonus show for you today
now i actually i don't know
pat had a very interesting incident over
the weekend and i wanted to talk to you
about it
uh although i don't know that we're
doing it today so we may have some very
interesting stories on the bonus show
today about golden bitcoin prices
spiking and trump's executive order on
drug prices
and some other things or we may have a
wacky
pat ford story from the weekend that i
think you're really really going to love
but i'm just not sure yet because i've
got to figure out which bonus show we're
doing today in any case
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinedpakman.com or becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash davidpakinshow
we'll see you then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor
is blinkist the app that lets you read
or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video